- Besides intense fans,
soaps are known for insane plot twists,
which are my favorite.
So in honor of 14,000 episodes,
can you give me your top
three crazy Marlena moments?
Like, can you, like what's number three?
If you had to pick the top three?
- Out of character at one point,
Marlena was the Salem
Strangler, several things,
where she went around
dressed in a black cape
and a black hood strangling people.
- That, you're like Jack
the Ripper, just like, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
And nobody saw it coming; it was perfect.
- That's amazing.
How 'bout number two?
- My sister played Hattie Adams,
who was this crazy,
crazy woman on the show.
And then when she went back to teaching,
they said you can step in and play her.
So I played Marlena for 40 years,
and she's very understanding
and compassionate and patient,
and not at all outrageous.
So playing Hattie was the most fun.
Oh my gosh.
- What's your number one Marlena moment?
- You know, I think the fans would agree,
I think it's gotta be possession.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] (laughs) You got a clap!
- [Deidre] I have a fan there?
Okay, good.
- Jason is freaking out,
my musical director.
- It was completely surprising,
and we've been watching things go,
oh, there it is, yeah.
That, by the way, I was up in the air.
- Now, wait, yeah, that's what
I was just about to ask you.
What happened there? How'd
you get that to do that?
- That was done, I can't
tell you most of it,
but that was actually,
I'm gonna say a circus trick.
- Oh my gosh.
- So there were other parts of that set
that you can't see there.
And I did literally lift off the bed--
- That's amazing.
- during the scene, right.
- I would've felt amazing in that moment.
- It was great.
- [Kelly] That's what I'm saying.
- Also relieved that it worked,
but it was Christmas Eve,
and everybody was in church,
and I was home alone, and there it went.
Oops, she's off the bed.
- Oh my God, I love it.
It's Christmas Eve, you're
possessed, this is amazing.
It's just amazing.
(audience laughs)